points all across the southern U.S
border migrant men women and children
can be seen arriving as title 42 expires
bring it this way about 400 have camped
near the border in El Paso Texas where
National Guard members erected barbed
wire migrants there were given a choice
returned to Mexico or board buses to
processing centers but we're going to
prevent any further migrants from
joining the group that's already here in
San Ysidro California the busiest port
of entry in the U.S hundreds of people
including toddlers braved rain and heat
using blankets border patrol estimates
about 60 thousand migrants are waiting
in northern Mexico while some 25 000 sit
in holding facilities where resources
are severely limited border patrol Chief
Raul Ortiz says authorities will now
lean on protocols outlined by the
decades-old title eight under which
migrants can be deported from the United
States back to their home countries and
given a five-year ban on re-entry unless
they express fear of returning and pass
an interview